[Music]
no
no no long time ago different life
now you come back yes i'm looking for
something
you can find whatever you wish in turkey
how about a man who kidnapped a little
girl from her american mother
would not be looking for such a man it
would be dangerous
for you man like him would think that
baby robert i'm your only friend
it's great you're helping all these
random people and everything
could stay off the radar something
happened to one of ours
so i'm obligated to look into it i
thought you were retired
oh i am just like you're dead
[Music]
yeah it's a matter
[Music]
they knew what floor she was on
they're tying up loose ends exactly
for seven years it's a mistake to go to
war with him
[Music]
here with the agency family you ever see
star trek
very good call 911
they killed my friend so i'm going to
kill each and every one of them and they
only disappoint me
is that i only get to do it once
seeing you carrying all those books
around i figured you feel some kind of
teacher i'm a high level paid club
assassins
i've done it already
how do i see
so
[Music]
nope
nice ride thanks how much for the car
she's not for sale
[Music]
daisy
jonathan you got out once it's personal
it's not what you did son it's who you
did it too nobody but nobody
[Music]
people keep asking if i'm back
yeah i'm thinking i'm back
i'm not afraid of john wick you should
be
you uh working again no just sorting
some stuff out
[Music]
what we know senior chief kelly is the
third member to be attacked
[Music]
three perps are dead
also killed was his wife
they better hope he doesn't survive why
is that
he is more dangerous and effective than
any man we have in the field
[Music]
he took everything from me
these were foreign attacks on u.s soil
we have to respond
i'm gonna make it right
[Music]
there's something inside of me that i
can't turn off
the part of me that won't stop for
anything
no remorse
has it occurred to you that perhaps john
kelly
has done something we can't
some situations you aren't thinking
outside the box
[Music]
give me your name you were supposed to
be dead give me your name
who's my girl
my girl has love in her heart and
snow in her eyes and peppermint
in her life happy birthday kiddo
mrs norris
i'm very sorry for your loss we have
three suspects in custody
but they're all linked to the garcia
cartel no witnesses have been willing to
step up
these cartels are no joke they've got
everyone in their pockets
you've been through a terrible tragedy
maybe you didn't see what you think you
saw
that's him maybe you've made a mistake
number three number five number four
they did it it's possible that your
recollection isn't what you thought it
was
the evidence is insufficient to hold the
defendants over for trial
you think that you're gonna have justice
make them all pay
five years ago riley north just
disappeared completely off the grid
so she spends the last five years doing
what training
well that's new you honestly think riley
north did this
today's the five year anniversary of her
family's murder
she's back
screw up judges dirty cops
what do i want i want justice
it's not a coincidence that makes this
area a little crime it is low crime
because of her
[Music]
at least somebody's doing something find
her
i don't care if you have to burn the
city down watching someone take
everything from you
it turns you into somebody else social
media is lit up with support for
she's a multiple homicide suspect
not to them she's not
out man how you really think this is
gonna go
i will kill every one of you and then
i'll pretty much wing it from there
dad oh my darling happy birthday
dad guess what you know my friend amanda
yep her cousins asked us to spend
vacation with them
in paris i really really want to go
hi daddy you were supposed to call me
when you land
there's someone here what oh my god they
got amanda
all right listen to me go to the next
bedroom under the bed
tell me when you're here now
the next part is very important they're
going to take you
i don't know who you are i don't know
what you want
if you're looking for ransom i can tell
you i don't have money
but what i do have are a very particular
set of skills
skills i have acquired over a very long
career
skills that make me a nightmare for
people like you
if you let my daughter go now that'll be
the end of it you have a 96 hour
what to never finding her no but if you
don't
i will look for you where is she i will
find you
i will kill you
good luck
[Music]
yeah go watch out for dinner pumpkinhead
okay i got it
you gotta get outta here what are you
doing come on
the sheldon case where are we let's make
the deal they killed a little girl there
some justice has been no justice at all
you need to tell the husband
no i don't understand with darby's
testimony ames will go to death row what
the jury's going to believe me i'm sorry
this is just how the justice system
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
works
what was supposed to be a painless
execution has turned into something out
of a horror film
the machine was corrupted who could have
done this
i killed your friend ames in prison but
i wanted to keep you all for myself your
heart
is beating so fast me too
did you murder clarence darby he killed
my wife and child
i guess we've done it counselor
you might want to cancel your 12 30
lunch with judge roberts
hello you and whoever else you have
helping you
are gonna pay now you're the one who
makes deals with murderers yeah
so i've come to make mine release me for
what
or i kill everyone we have him locked up
and he's still killing people
i found a couple of contract payments
from the department of defense
tell us what we're dealing with the spy
spies are a diamond doesn't
quite as a brain and he was the best if
clyde wants you dead
you're dead we're gonna lock this city
down put an armed cop on every corner
he's in jail because he wants to be in
jail
i'm gonna bring the whole system down on
your head
it's gotta be biblical
you were in this i'm just getting warmed
up
i wish i wasn't afraid all the time but
i am
[Music]
[Applause]
people should not be afraid of their
governments
governments should be afraid of their
people
those caught in violation of curfew will
be prosecuted without
leniency or exception it's past
oh curfew tonight
who are you gentlemen i want this
terrorist foul
and i want him to understand what terror
really means
we're working on several leaves her
parents were detained when she was 12.
it was like those black bags erased them
from the face of the earth
you have one chance you must tell us the
whereabouts of codename lee
[Music]
the time has come for you to live
without fear
i'm ready this country stands on the
edge of oblivion
so remember why they need
i suddenly had this feeling that
everything was connected
we're all part of it
are we ready for it
the only verdict is vengeance
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
who is he will remove your helmet and
tell me your name
my name is gladiator father to a
murdered son
husband to a murdered wife and i will
have my venues
today i saw a slave become more powerful
than the emperor of rome
they said you were a giant i shall cheer
for you
eternity
[Applause]
oh
have i told you i love you yes dad
you've told me like a billion times
honey you please come down here
doc something has happened you can't go
in there
dad where's mom i love
my family i failed to protect him
i'm sorry dr kersey nothing yet so
there's nothing that i can do is that
what you're saying
can i have faith
have faith work out for them
if a man really wants to protect what's
his
he has to do it for himself the men who
did it
are out there i'm gonna hunt them down
one by one i had homies in the never
break doing gun trains head out the dark
we're closed pal you're joey right yeah
well kill my wife
who else was there i don't know anything
else
you're not going to kill me no jackass
can't deny me now you got caught in some
crossfire yeah you said next time and it
will be my leg
you are going to be all right i promise
you're not a cop somebody has to do it
everybody's watching this viral video is
this dude right for taking the law into
his own hands
she keeps my life or is it wrong
you're cocked locked and ready to work
i'll see
someone took my wife everyone involved
is going to pay
you look much better getting out
socializing um
not so much well whatever you're doing
keep it up okay
i will
django let me ask you a question how'd
you like the bounty hunting business
i like it a lot we make a good team
what's your plan john go free my wife
i'm pretty good at finding people why
you care if i found my wife
i've never given anybody their freedom
before
i feel responsible for him calvin candy
he owns candyland it would appear i can
choose to do with my property whatever i
so desire
how they confirmed that your wife is in
candyland
[Music]
so you really free yes you mean you want
to dress like that
smooth is more important than fast more
important than smooth is accurate
i like the way you die boy
live my whole life here in candyland
surrounded by black
faces everything you see is my property
i
ain't impressed well i've heard tell
about you
bullseye something up with these two
you know boys done rolled a lot of miles
went to a lot of trouble just to get
that gap hey little troublemaker
[Music]
you silver tongue w
they playing your ass for food
your boss looks a little green around
the gills i'm just a little more used to
americans in here
it's time to rescue your wife that's
what i'm doing
i'm getting dirty
[Music]
[Applause]
y'all ain't gonna make it out of this
county alive
sons of [ __ ] no doubt
happy thanksgiving happy thanksgiving
can i take joy to our house wear a hat
please you're just getting over
cold where are your sisters
i can't find them hannah
joy i checked the entire house they're
not here
dad there's this rv and they were
playing on it there was then we thought
there was someone inside
here let me know i couldn't find them
9-1-1 detective loki do you have
children detectives
i'm going to find your daughters
what do you got we didn't find anything
this thing's clean that boy has never
been in trouble a day in his life
they're letting him go what the police
said they're letting him go today
why aren't you saying someone had to go
arrest this guy well he has the iq of a
10 year old there's no way he could
abduct two girls and then make them
disappear maybe he wasn't on his own
we're considering all possibilities i
don't think you are considering all
possibilities just let me do my job
keep knocking on doors mind if i take a
look around
why do you tell me his name he said he
took them did he say he was with anybody
we found something someone has to make
him talk
or they're gonna die five days have been
gone now we run out of time
you don't even know that it's him he
left him with someone and he knows where
this guy is
this guy's a fake you're doing him tell
me well no no no the girls are still out
there
[Music]
you